[Musique]
merci de
pouvoir aimer vous exprimer J'ai
beaucoup de gens qui ne sont pas ici dans l'
enclos Holman donc vous avez un temps après 12h12.
[Musique]
Je suis une première génération  cowgirl mon père
et ma mère, ils connaissaient les
chevaux mais nous n'avons jamais vraiment su grand-chose
sur le rodéo comme le sport lui-même, donc nous
apprenions au fur et à mesure que nous avancions. Je veux être cette
cowgirl noire que d'autres petites
cowgirls de couleur mâle ou femelle peuvent
regarde et dis bien qu'elle l'a fait donc je
sais que je peux aussi
[Musique]
Je réalise aussi de manière réaliste en tant qu'adulte
et en tant que père
leurs restrictions financières
et
je ne peux pas nécessairement me permettre de lui offrir
le genre  de cheval qui fera d'elle une
championne, nous ferons de notre mieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cela montre que peu importe à quoi vous
ressemblez ou quoi que ce soit, vous pouvez faire tout ce que vous
avez en tête  confiance et sachez que vous
pouvez vous pouvez le faire
savent que beaucoup d'entre
eux ont grandi dedans et du show business en ce qui concerne le
cirque de rodéo, donc ils
ont les parrainages qu'ils
transmettent à leurs enfants, ils avaient l'
argent pour la terre et des choses comme ça,
je veux surtout que les femmes noires voient
que c'est ici c'est disponible
[Musique]
étranger